alarming new evidence of a spike in the
pandemic among those who have not
received a vaccine a month ago the
highly contagious delta variant
accounted for just over 2 percent of
coveted cases in america
now that number is up to 20 percent this
comes as the white house said it will
not
reach president biden's vaccination
goals by the fourth of july
omar villafranca is in branson missouri
a state with the distinction
of leading the country in new covet
cases per capita
omar good morning what are officials
they're saying
well here they're saying that people
just need to get vaccinated it's that
lack of vaccination that's causing the
virus to spike
here in the branson area only one in
four people are
fully vaccinated and that's left a lot
of people vulnerable in this tourist
town with its ferris wheels and all the
shows
right at a time where they're about to
see the biggest crowds of the year
it's summer in the ozarks a popular
vacation destination for midwesterners
and
southerners alike but right now the
region is one of the hottest hot spots
for covid19
according to dr terence coulter what do
you worry about i'm worried about the
perfect storm brewing
with the lifting of the mask mandates
the vacationers coming and going
the low immunization rates and then now
the arrival of the delta variant which
is highly prevalent in the area
we're a hot spot and this is just going
to explode outward
the delta variant is being blamed for a
sharp rise in hospitalizations in
southwest missouri
up 196 percent in the last month
the variant now accounts for nearly half
of all coveted cases
across 10 states at cox health in
springfield
it's been detected in the majority of
patients who are the people who are
ending up in your hospitals now
disturbingly what we're seeing is more
and more younger patients being admitted
and these are of course the unvaccinated
this is the gap in our armor
they feel they don't really need it
they're invincible that's exactly how 50
year old louis michael felt
well you think you're strong and you're
physically in shape and you're
moving along just fine until he and his
wife patty
ended up at a missouri hospital last
week due to complications from
covid michael told us from his hospital
room he was on the fence about the shot
he hadn't caught the virus yet and
wasn't sure he ever would
i got a little cocky about it and now
that we've got this new variant this new
strain
it seems to be dive bombing everybody
that didn't have any problems before
and so i regret not having it if you can
go and
get this shot now and bypass what we've
been through the last two weeks
because you feel like you're gonna die
it's horrible
dr coulter said at the peak of the
pandemic seven
people were dying a day at his hospital
and i said are you ready for another
surge and he said
we have to be anthony
omar thank you